>> RUN OUT AND CLAIM IT'S
REPUBLICANS WHO WANT TO DEFUND
THE POLICE.
THAT'S LIKE AN ARSONIST SHOWING
UP AT A FIRE AND BLAMING THE
FIREMEN.
THAT'S LIKE THE CHINESE BLAMING
THE AMERICANS FOR THE WUHAN
VIRUS.
THAT'S LIKE O.J. SAYING HE IS
GOING TO HELP FIND THE REAL
KILLER.
THAT'S LIKE DEMOCRATS SAYING
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT WANT TO
BUILD THE WALL.
IT'S ABSURD.
IT'S RIDICULOUS, AND THEY KNOW
IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY ARE ALSO COUNTING ON THE
MEDIA ALL ENCIRCLE LING JOE
BIDEN AND SAYING POOR UNCLE JOE
HE DOESN'T WANT TO ABOLISH YOUR
POLICE.
LAST TIME I CHECKED BILL DE
BLASIO THE DEMOCRATIC MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CAMPAIGNED ON DEFUNDING
THE POLICE.
CUT A BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
NYPD AND, DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
DE BLASIO WAS STANDING ON THAT
SAME DEMOCRATIC STAGE WITH JOE
BIDEN.
AINSLEY: YEAH.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE FACING A LOT
OF BACKLASH AS THEY ARE TRYING
TO BLAME THE REPUBLICANS TO PUSH
TO TEE FUND THE POLICE.
STEVE: WELL, SEAN HANNITY JOINS
US RIGHT NOW.
HE IS UP EARLY.
HE HAS A BIG DAY.
SEAN: IT'S A MIRACLE.
I'M UP EARLY HOW DID THAT EVER
HAPPEN?  SEAN.
BRIAN: DID YOU GO TO BED?
>> ABOUT 3:30.
ABOUT WHEN YOU GET UP FOR WORK.
BRIAN: THAT'S UP LATE FOR US WE
ARE UP EARLIER THAN THAT.
AINSLEY: SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> YOU KEEP KEEP YOUR HOURS
TOUGHEST IN TV.
TED CRUZ WAS FUNNY LAST NIGHT.
SO, WE WATCHED LAST SUMMER
HORRIBLE RIGHT?
WE ARE WATCHING CITY BLOCKS
BEING TAKEN OVER, SUMMER OF LOVE
ZONE.
CHAZ, CHOP, AUTONOMOUS ZONE,
POLICE PRECINCTS BEING BURNED TO
THE GROUND.
WE WATCHED THE LOOTING, THE
RIOTING.
WE WATCHED 3,000 COPS INJURED,
PELTED WITH ROCKS, BRICKS,
WATER -- FROZEN WATER BOTTLES,
AND BY THE WAY ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE APPARENTLY ARE NOT GOING
TO BE CHARGED IN WHAT THEY DID.
AND NOW THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
ALMOST COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY
SILENT AND REFUSE TO CALL THEM
RIOTS NOW THEY HAVE DECIDED TO
SAY IT'S THE PRODUCTION' FAULT.
GEORGE ORWELL WAS A LITTLE AHEAD
OF HIS TIME BECAUSE THAT'S ABOUT
AS 1984ISH AS I CAN THINK OF.
STEVE: SEAN, THE DEMOCRATS HAD
TO THINK OF A NEW STRATEGY AND
NARRATIVE BECAUSE CRIME IS
THROUGH THE ROOF.
LAST WEEK, OUT OF NOWHERE.
JOE BIDEN SAID HE MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT, YOU KNOW, AND BY
THE WAY, POLICE CAN USE THE
MONEY FROM THE COVID BILL.
AND THAT'S NEW.
AND SO THEN JEN PSAKI EARLIER
THIS WEEK WAS TALKING ABOUT
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE REPUBLICANS
WHO DEFUNDED THE POLICE BECAUSE
THEY WOULD NOT VOTE FOR THE
$1.9 TRILLION.
SEAN: RIDICULOUS.
STEVE: COVID BILL WHICH DOES NOT
ANYWHERE IN THE BILL MENTION
POLICE.
SEAN: KAMALA HARRIS PRAISED THE
DEFUNDING EFFORTS THAT TOOK
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA AND LOS
ANGELES SPECIFICALLY.
KAMALA HARRIS ALSO PROMOTED THE
BAIL FUND IN MINNEAPOLIS.
IT WAS NEW YORK CITY THAT CUT A
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE POLICE
BUNGEGHT CRIME WEPT THROUGH THE
ROOF.
THEN THEY COME UP WITH THESE
INSANE NO BAIL LAWS WHICH IS
THAT IF THEY CATCH YOU, BRIAN,
YOU BETTER BE CAREFUL, YOUR BANK
ROBBER IN YOUR SPARE TIME.
IF YOU ROB A BANK -- LITERALLY,
THERE WAS ONE BANK ROBBER THAT
WAS ON THE FRONT COVER OF ONE OF
THE TABLOIDS IN NEW YORK.
ROBS A BANK, THERE IS NO BAIL.
THEY LET HIM OUT.
HE GOES OUT AND ROBS ANOTHER
BANK.
THEY LET HIM OUT, HE ROBS
ANOTHER BANK.
IS HE LIKE THANKING GOVERNOR
CUOMO AND COMRADE DE BLASIO FOR
ALLOWING HIM TO CONTINUE THIS
VERY IMPORTANT CRAFT OF HIS AND
PROFESSION WHICH IS ROBBING
BANKS BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T PUT
THEM IN JAIL.
THAT'S THE SAME THING THAT THEY
WERE DOING TO THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WERE RIOTING AND LOOTING AND
INVOLVED AN ARSON.
LOOK, IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE THIS
IS HAPPENING, LAST YEAR WE HAD
RECORD INCREASES IN VIOLENT
CRIME IN EVERY CASE THESE ARE
BLUE STATES, BLUE CITIES RUN BY
DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT PUSHED
THE DEFUNDING OF THE POLICE.
IT'S TWISTED LOGIC ON THEIR
PART.
ONE OF THE REACHES I THINK THEY
ARE DOING IT IS BECAUSE POLLING
NOW SHOWS OVERWHELMINGLY THAT
THE OVERWHELMING DEMOCRATS FOR
POLICIES THAT ARE NOT KEEPING
LAW AND ORDER.
SIMPLE CONCEPT.
IF WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO PURSUE
HAPPINESS, RIGHT?
WE ARE ENDOWED -- WE COULD TELL
JOE BIDEN CREATOR, GOD, THE
CREATOR OF EVERYTHING.
WE ARE ENDOWED BY OUR CREATOR.
LIFE, LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE LAW AND ORDER,
AND SAFETY AND SECURITY, YOU
CANNOT PURSUE HAPPINESS.
AND SADLY, THAT IS THE CASE FOR
WAY TOO MANY PEOPLE AND WAY TOO
MANY CITIES.
IT'S A PROBLEM WE DO KNOW HOW TO
SOLVE IF WE SET OUR BEHIND TO
SOLING IT.
AINSLEY: THE FOLKS DON'T LIKE
DEFUNDING AND THEY DON'T LIKE
WHAT'S HAPPENING DOWN ON THE
BORDER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HEADING
THERE.
KAMALA WENT LAST WEEK.
AND THEN WE JUST LEARNED THIS
MORNING,.
SEAN: SEAN SHE KIND OF WENT
THERE LAST WEEK.
SHE WENT THERE FOR A PHOTO OP.
LAST WEEK BUT NOT WHERE ALL THE
WHERE SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
STEVE: DETOUR ON HER TRIP TO
L.A.
AINSLEY: SEAN, WE LEARNED THIS
MORNING THERE WAS A 2-YEAR-OLD
CHILD FOUND ON THE MEXICO SIDE
ABANDONED ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD.
WE KEEP SEEING THESE STORIES.
WE KEEP SEEING THESE IMAGES.
HERE'S THE PICTURE OF IT.
SEAN: WOW.
BUT, YOU KNOW, AINSLEY, WE HAVE
SEEN THIS BEFORE.
YOU KNOW, HOW MANY TIMES -- ALL
RIGHT, THE WALLS THAT ARE BUILT
AND YOU SEE PEOPLE LITERALLY
PULLING THESE CHILDREN UP TO THE
TOP OF THE WALL AND DUMPING THEM
OVER, DROPPING THEM OVER.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE -- YOU KNOW,
ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO IMAGINE IF
DONALD TRUMP WERE PRESIDENT AND
I AGREE WITH STEVE THAT THE ONLY
REASON THAT KAMALA HARRIS MADE
AN ATTEMPT AT THIS PHOTO OP.,
WHICH IS WHAT IT TURNED OUT TO
BE, IS BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP
ANNOUNCED THAT HE WAS GOING TO
THE BORDER.
WE WILL BE THERE WITH HIM.
WE WILL BE THERE WITH GREG
ABBOTT TODAY.
IS BECAUSE HE WENT THERE.
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP AS
PRESIDENT IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC AND THE IMAGES THAT WE
SAW OF REALLY I CALL THEM --
THEY'RE CAGES, THEY ARE PLASTIC
CAGES BUT THE KIDS WERE TRAPPED
INSIDE THEM.
THEY HAD NO OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD
THEM.
THEY ARE OVERCROWDED IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
LIVING ON TOP OF EACH OTHER.
HIGH RATE OF TESTING POSITIVE
FOR COVID,.
BRIAN: MILITARY BASES.
SEAN: MILITARY BASES.
AINSLEY: SEXUAL ASSAULT?
>> Sean: EXACTLY.
THEN THEY WOULDN'T ALLOW THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS TO SEND IN
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES TO
EVEN LOOK AT THESE CHILDREN.
NOW, YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF WE DON'T PROTECT THESE KIDS,
WE'RE DOING EVERYBODY A
DISSERVICE HERE.
IT'S A 25-YEAR HIGH.
WE'RE PROBABLY ON RECORD NOW TO
BRING IN MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE DARK OF NIGHT,
THEY ARE LITERALLY TRANSPORTING
THEM TO ALL THE DIFFERENT STATES
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THEN THE STATES ARE BURDENED
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT ALLOW TO
THE CIRCUMVENT FEDERAL LAW, IT
GETS A LITTLE COMPLICATED.
STATES RESPONSIBLE FOR FOOD,
WATER, SHELTER, FOR HEALTHCARE
AND EDUCATION, AND WE CAN BARELY
AFFORD IT FOR AMERICAN CITIZENS
RIGHT NOW IT.
BRIAN: GOVERNOR OF TEXAS AND
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
ARE YOU GOING TO BE SEEING WHAT
THEY ARE DOING TONIGHT BRINGING
THAT TO THE SHOW TOWN HALL.
YOU KNOW, BRIAN, IF YOU WOULD
HAVE TOLD ME THAT JOE BIDEN'S
ECONOMY WOULD BE THIS BAD THIS
QUICKLY.
I DON'T THINK I WOULD HAVE
LITTLE BIT LONGER.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE TOLD ME THEY
WOULD OPEN THE BORDERS, IT'S
BEYOND OPEN BORDERS, YOU DON'T
GET TO PICK AND CHOOSE IN
AMERICA.
NONE OF US ARE ALLOWED TO PICK
AND CHOOSE WHAT LAWS CHOOSE WHAT
LAWS WE CHOOSE NOT TO OBEY.
NOT ONLY IS JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS -- THEY ARE CHOOSING NOT
TO ENFORCE THE LAWS OF THE LAND.
RESPECTING OUR LAW, OUR BORDERS,
OUR SOVEREIGNTY.
THEN THEY ARE AIDING AND
ABETTING IN THE LAW-BREAKING
BECAUSE THEY ARE ONLY PROCESSING
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING, IN THEY
ABOLISH THE STAY?
MEXICO PROGRAM, HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL BASICALLY CATCH AND
WILL PROCESS YOU AND HAVE A GOOD
LIFE IN KAMALA.
PROVIDING ALL OF THE SERVICES ON
THE BACKS OF THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER.
I'M ALL FOR IMMIGRATION LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
BRIAN: THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
FOCUS TONIGHT.
BRIAN: THAT WILL BE A BIG PART
OF IT THE OTHER THING IS 90% OF
THE HEROIN IN THIS COUNTRY COMES
ACROSS THAT BORDER.
WE HAVE AN OPIOID CRISIS.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
SEAN: 95% OF THE FENTANYL IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT IS KILLING
MANY CHILDREN ON AVERAGE, 300
AMERICANS A WEEK ARE DYING.
THAT IS CROSSING THAT SOUTHERN
BORDER.
I HAVE BEEN DOWN TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IN THE COURSE OF MY
CAREER THIS MIGHT BE MY 15TH
TIME.
I HAVE BEEN BY THE WAY IF YOU
WANT TO SEE REALLY FUNNY FILM,
WATCH ME ON HORSEBACK.
I HAVE BEEN ON HORSEBACK ALL
TERRAIN VEHICLES.
STEVE: CHOPPERS, BOATS?
SEAN: HELICOPTERS, PLANES, I
HAVE SEEN DRUG WAREHOUSES RIO
GRANDE ALL THE WAY TO SAN DIEGO.
I HAVE SEEN LITERALLY TUNNELS
BUILT FROM MEXICO ALL THE WAY UP
TO OFFICE BUILDING IN SAN DIEGO.
THE PROBLEM IS SEVERE.
BUT TRUMP HAD FIXED IT.
THIS PROBLEM WAS RESOLVED.
NOW WE ARE ABOUT TO HIT A 25-30
YEAR HIGH OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
IN THE COUNTRY AND WE'RE NOT
EVEN -- WE'RE NOT EVEN
DEPOVERTYING ILLEGAL CRIMINAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AINSLEY: SEAN I WAS LOOKING UP.
STEVE: WE WILL BE WATCHING
TONIGHT.
AINSLEY: TALKING ABOUT OAKLAND
AND ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
CITIES IN OUR COUNTRY.
LOOKING UP MOST DANGEROUS CITIES
THIS MORNING AND IT GAVE ME
CITIES IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
THERE WERE THREE, I THINK ON THE
TOP 10 LIST ALL ALONG THE BORDER
OF MEXICO.
THOSE ARE THE FOLKS WHO LIVE
THERE WHO WANT TO COME IN OUR
COUNTRY AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS LETTING THEM
JUST COME IN FREE WILLY-NILLY
THEY CAN WALK RIGHT OVER.
SEAN: YOU KNOW, THERE IS A HUMAN
COMPASSION SIDE TO THIS DEBAIT.
IT'S GOT TO BE DONE.
I REMEMBER I WAS STANDING IN SAN
DIEGO RIGHT ON THE BORDER.
AND ON THE SAN DIEGO SIDE
500,000 HOMES.
MILLION DOLLARS HOMES AND THEN
ON THE OTHER SIDE YOU SEE
NOTHING BUT UTTER POVERTY.
IT'S NOT AMERICA'S ROLE,
HOWEVER, TO BRING EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THAT CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
LOOK, THERE ARE THREE CRITERIA I
WOULD HAVE FOR ENTRY INTO
AMERICA.
NUMBER ONE, I WOULD MAKE IT THAT
WE HAVE TO HAVE A BACKGROUND
CHECK SO WE KNOW THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE RADICAL ASSOCIATIONS.
POST COVID, I WOULD SAY ANYBODY
THAT WANTS TO ENTER THE COUNTRY
LEGALLY, THEY WOULD NEED TO
HEALTH CHECK OF SOME KIND AND
THE THIRD THING I THINK PEOPLE
WOULD NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVE
IS THAT THEY ARE ABLE AND
CAPABLE FINANCIALLY TO TAKE CARE
OF THEMSELVES.
THEN GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
LEGALLY AND I DON'T CARE WHERE
YOU COME FROM, MY ANSWER IS
WELCOME TO AMERICA.
WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
STEVE: INDEED, ONE MORE TOPIC
BEFORE YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
GO, THAT IS OUR PRESIDENT HAS
ADOPTED A NEW WAY OF
COMMUNICATING.
HE DID IT YESTERDAY AGAIN.
THE WAY HE DID IT LAST WEEK AND
ESSENTIALLY IT'S GEORGE BUSH.
IT'S READ MY LIPS I'M WHISPERING
[WHISPERING] WATCH, WATCH.
>> WAITING FOR RELIEF.
[WHISPERING] I GOT THEM
$1.9 TRILLION RELIEF SO FAR.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO BE GETTING
CHECKS IN THE MAIL THAT ARE
CONSEQUENTIAL.
[WHISPERING] I WROTE THE BILL ON
THE ENVIRONMENT.
WHY WOULD I NOT BE FOR IT?
[WHISPERING] PAY THEM MORE.
THIS IS AN EMPLOYEE'S BARGAINING
CHIP NOW.
>> HEY, GUYS.
[WHISPERING] I THINK IT'S TIME
TO GIVE ORDINARY PEOPLE
STEVE: SO SHAWN HANNITY, ON
WHISPERING WEDNESDAY, CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHY HE'S TALKING LIKE
THAT?
>> YES, I ACTUALLY CAN, BUT
SOME PEOPLE GET ANGRY THAT I DO
IT.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR
QUITE A WHILE, WE'VE BEEN
SHOWING TAPE ON HANNITY.
JOE BIDEN IN 2012, JOE BIDEN IN
2016, JOE BIDEN TODAY, HOW DO I
SAY THIS NICELY, I CALL HIM VERY
AFFECTION ATLY PRESIDENT SIPPY
CUP BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK AT JOE'S SCHEDULE HE
HAS LESS THAN ONE ITEM A DAY ON
HIS AGENDA, THEY HIDE HIM AS
OFTEN AS POSSIBLE, DID YOU
EVER IMAGINE WE'D HAVE A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT'S CONSTANTLY SAYING, I
CAN'T ANSWER QUESTIONS BECAUSE
THEY ARE GOING TO GET MAD AT ME.
THEY ARE GOING TO YELL AT ME.
HE GOES TO BED AT LIKE 7:00 AT
NIGHT, HE GETS HIS WARM MILK,
HIS SIPPY CUP, MAYBE A NIGHT-
NIGHT STORY AND PART OF IT
IS FUNNY BUT NOW TO ME IT'S
GETTING A LITTLE SCARY BECAUSE
IT'S EMBOLDENING PEOPLE THAT
DON'T LIKE US LIKE VLADIMIR
PUTIN, PRESIDENT XI OF CHINA,
KIM JONG-UN, RADICAL ISLAMIC
TERRORISTS, I AM VERY VERY
CONCERNED.
HE LOOKS WEAK, FRAIL, HE'S A
COGNITIVE MESS AND STEVE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT LITTLE
WISPER THING IS ALL ABOUT BUT
IT'S VERY ODD, BIZARRE, AND
STRANGE TO ME.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY I CAN EXPLAIN
IT.
STEVE: EVERY TIME HE DOES IT, HE
MAKES A HIGHLIGHT.
AINSLEY: AND SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE
>> EVERYONE WANTS ME TO GIVE
THEM, I HAD SIPPY CUPS MADE UP
WITH THE PRESIDENTIAL SEAL ON IT
EVERYBODY WANTS THEM.
BRIAN:  IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG
HIT.
I CAN SEE.
>> I'LL BRING ONE TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP DOWN AT THE BORDER TONIGHT
BRIAN:  IT'LL BE AS BIG OF A HIT
AS THE GUTFELD T-SHIRT WHICH IS
CAPTURING AMERICA'S IMAGINATION.
>> WELL, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
POLICIES WORKED.
THE POLICIES NOW ARE NOT WORKING
BY THE WAY AND LOOK HOW HARD IT
IS ON GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
LEGALLY HE'S NOT ALLOWED TO
ENFORCE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW,
SO NOW, HE'S GOT TO SPEND
$250 MILLION AS A START TO
CONTINUE BUILDING THE WALL
DONALD TRUMP WAS BUILDING.
BRIAN:  LET ME JUST TELL YOU HOW
POWERFUL YOU ARE.
YOU'RE THE FIRST GUEST WE'VE HAD
IN THE HISTORY OF OUR SHOW THAT
NO ONE IN OUR EAR IS SAYING WRAP
>> I DON'T WRAP UP MY OWN SHOW.
BRIAN:  THEY AREN'T EVEN TELLING
US TO WRAP YOU.
AINSLEY: CAN YOU STAY FOR
ANOTHER HOUR, SEAN?
>> WHAT'S THAT?
AINSLEY: CAN YOU STAY FOR
ANOTHER HOUR?
>> I'M SURE I COULD.
I'LL BE A LITTLE LATE FOR THE
INTERVIEW.
AINSLEY: WE'LL BE WATCHING YOU
TONIGH